WAYNE PIEKARSKI: We hope you're
having a good conference.
So it's almost into day two.
So JP just gave us a great
talk before about some design
work for Android Wear.
And so now what we're
going to talk about
is about making your apps
work on the Always On screen
support that's available
on Android Wear.
So it's a really cool feature
where your screen is always
operating to show
you information.
So we're going to give a
little talk about this today.
So we've got JP here.
JP GIL: So I had to
give a little talk
just right before about
how to make your watch face
interactive.
And when I showed that, I
showed that it can actually
have an always on mode
for a watch faces.
As Wayne mentioned, we can do
that for your apps as well.
And I'm a designer at
the Android Wear team.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So
I'm Wayne Piekarski
and I'm a developer advocate.
And I work on Android
Wear plus a bunch
of other different products.
And so we're going to give a
little talk today about some
of the best design principles
for working with the Always On
screen.
And there's our contact details
if you want to follow us
on Google+ or Twitter.
And then also, we have an
Android Wear developers' group
on Google+ that you can
also check out as well.
But Anyway, let's get
started with our talk.
So I'll pass it off to JP.
JP GIL: So when you
look at this screen,
here-- when you think
about an Always On screen,
you think about LCDs.
So they're very low battery.
They last forever.
But the problem with
them is that you actually
have to think about
all the information
that you want to pack in
that screen beforehand.
Right?
So you have to make
a lot of choices
before you decide
what to put in there.
And once they're in there you
can't change them anymore.
So they're very power efficient.
You know that they're going
to work for a long time.
But if you need any
other kind of information
you're not going to
have it because it's not
going to change.
It's not very flexible.
So with Android Wear, we
are the first smart watch
that allows you to have the
flexibility of, like, color
LCDs, color displays,
that we can update
the pixels any time with
the Always On functionality,
as well.
That pretty much mimics
what happens on an LCD
with much more flexibility.
You don't have to
design beforehand.
So basically, you
can have information
that's there all the time
in a low power fashion
saving your battery,
and actually
not disconnecting the
user from the experience
that they're going through.
So as an example, here you're
looking at the watch face.
I don't know if you're familiar
with Android or watch faces.
We've been having
these experiences
for watch faces since the
beginning, just to save power.
So basically, you have
your time and then
it switches to low power mode.
You remove all the pixels,
like the color pixels,
and try to just display the
information that you need
with as little
pixels as possible,
let's say 5% of the
pixels that you need,
just using black and white.
But you don't need
to show just time.
You can also get your
next notification.
You look at the
notification, oh, Jeff
sent me a notification.
Plans for tonight?
And then if you
want to know more,
you just tap on the
watch face and then
it brings up to full power
and you can interact with it.
And this can apply for different
kinds of notifications,
different kinds of experiences,
like playing music or going
through navigation directions.
As an example,
like for microapps,
let's say you have an
app from your airline.
And then you're going
through your airport
and you have your QR code.
Originally, in Android
Wear when we launched,
every time you had a
microapp open, when
the display powered down you
would just close the microapp.
And you're in an airport,
a situation like this,
your QR code is right
there in front of you.
All of a sudden it's
not there anymore.
But now you can just
program your app
to actually use Always On mode.
And then it just dims the
display, goes to low power,
and stays there.
So the activity is just going
to stay there until you actually
interact with it.
So you don't lose it.
You just keep the same thread.
Think about like when you
are in a commute in a city.
You're looking at what's going
to be your next stop, when
your next train is coming.
And then if that information
is very important
and you lose it at the right
time, what's the use of it?
Right?
So you can actually
switch that to also use
low power mode as well.
Another example is if you
go into a grocery store
and you're trying to
look for things to buy.
If you're looking
at a list, you know
what's going to come next,
what is going to come before.
But if the list disappears,
what's the use of it, again?
Right?
So here's an example.
You're going to buy chocolate.
And I just enter low power mode.
And the developer decided
to just show the time
there to actually even
add more information.
So you keep the
information of the app
but it also adds information
of the watch face as well.
Now I'm going to pass it
on to Wayne, who's going
to tell you how to build this.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
Awesome, thanks.
OK.
So you've seen some of
the compelling use cases
of why Always On is so awesome.
So now what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to show you how to take
your existing Android Wear app
and retrofit it to activate
this Always On mode.
So the first thing
you've got to do
is you need to tweak
your build.gradle file.
So now if you're booting
an Android Wear app,
you probably have
these things already.
So if you look, we've got
the wearable support library
and we have Google
Play services.
So typically, you're
going to have that
if you're doing data layer
or anything like that.
And you're going to
have the support library
if you're using any of
the little widgets that
are provided.
If you don't have it,
add the support to it.
Now one trick with
Always On mode
is you've got to have this
provided section in the middle,
there.
That was added as part
of the Always On support.
So make sure you put
that in, otherwise you
have link problems later on.
So this is pretty simple.
As I said, most of
you already got it.
And one final thing is there's
a plus symbol in the top right.
So the plus symbol is
a gradle thing that
means grab the latest version.
Now you can also specify a
specific version like 8.3.
You can choose which
one is more appropriate.
The catch with pluses
is that the version
might change in the future
and it might break something.
So you can actually
fix the version in.
And I think current version
of Wearable Support Library
is 1.3.
But, anyway.
So you make that
little change there.
And the next thing
you need to do
is you tweak your Android
manifest.xml file.
Once again, pretty simple.
You need to request
wake lock permissions.
That's because due to the way
that the Always On mode feature
runs, you have to have the
ability to grab a wake lock.
So you add that in as well.
And then the next thing is you
need to specify in the manifest
that you're using
this wearable library,
and you need to specify this
in the manifest, as well.
If you leave these features
out, the support won't work.
So make sure you put that in.
So we've added the build
tools changes necessary.
Now we're going to show you
how to make the little tweaks
to the code to put this on.
So your code is
already going to be
extending a wearable activity,
so you've probably already got
this.
But you can see here
we've got our activity,
it extends wearable activity.
There are some people who
have wearable apps that
don't extend wearable activity.
You'll have to rejig
your app to do that.
Most people are doing that.
In your own onCreate method,
which you already have,
as well, you need to make a one
line call to setAmbientEnabled.
That tells the
Android Wear framework
that your app is aware of
Always On mode support.
If you don't put that in, it
won't do the necessary calls
to your app.
And if you let the screen
idle too long your app will
be dismissed, just like before.
So very important
you put that in.
Next, in your
activity there is--
you need to declare a method
called onEnterAmbient.
So the framework will
call onEnterAmbient
when it detects that the screen
is about to-- you can see here,
my watch is active.
And then eventually
it goes dark.
It's entering ambient mode when
it goes dark at that point.
So it calls your
onEnterAmbient method.
You need to call
super onEnterAmbient
to call the default version.
And then you need to do
things that reduce what's
being shown on the display.
So for example, in
this code snippet
here, you can see that we're
taking the background color
and we're setting it
probably to black.
So the mAmbientBgColor,
we've used that.
So this is reducing what's
shown on the display.
And then we leave our
method and then we're done.
Now, you can see here
we have a fragment.
We've passed this on to that
to also recolor that as well.
So that's it.
So we're just tweaking the
display and then our app
continues to run and that's it.
Next step, onExitAmbient.
This method is called when
the screen is becoming active
again.
So we're entering
interactive mode.
We want to enable full color,
full interactivity, things
like that.
You can see that we're setting
the background color back
to the active color, there.
Basically the same code,
but just done in reverse.
So those are the
two changes, there.
Now, this takes care of going
in the transition states
but what it doesn't
take care of is how we
go about refreshing the screen.
So refreshing the screen
is really important.
Now, what you don't want
to do is be in ambient mode
but your app is once a second
trying to refresh the screen.
That's a bad idea because
refreshing the screen
is expensive.
The CPU has to wake up.
The display uses power
to refresh itself.
When it's in this
low power state,
the screen needs to be kept
static and not changing
and with as little pixels
as possible illuminated.
So we have this
onUpdateAmbient method
which is called by the
framework once per minute.
It's an opportunity for your
app to refresh itself and maybe
draw something like a
clock on your application.
So if you've got
your shopping list,
it would be kind of sad if
you've got your shopping list
but, it's like, well, what's
the actual time right now?
So typically, apps that
run in ambient mode
should have a little
clock somewhere
that shows the
current time, as well.
So onUpdateAmbient is a method
that gives you the opportunity
to refresh this
clock once a minute
and then refresh the display.
As I said, you don't want to
do this very often because it
wastes a lot of power.
So always, when you're
developing an Android Wear app,
think about the user's
battery and the impact
it's going to have on them,
because if your app's doing
all this stuff,
it's going to make
the battery performance terrible
over the end of the day.
So you're given this call.
Don't do too much work in it.
So update your clock, but
don't do any heavy computations
because that's going to
waste CPU time as well.
You just want to get in and out.
And all we're doing here
is we're just saying, OK.
We've gotten our call.
Invalidate the view.
And it's just going
to refresh it quickly.
And that's it.
So there's no big amount
of work being done here.
Now, it is possible to update
the screen more often if it's
super important for you.
So for example,
the stopwatch app
that comes with Android
Wear has the ability
to refresh the screen a bit
more often because typically.
If you're timing
something, you want
to see it updating more often.
So you have the ability to use
the alarm manager to request
a real time clock that will pull
the CPU out of a sleep state,
but you can't use
things like handlers.
They're not allowed to work
when you're in ambient mode.
So generally, try--
if you're doing
some work where you're like,
I'll just use this hack
to try to make the CPU wake
up and refresh the screen,
you're probably doing
something wrong.
It's a bad idea to try to
work around the framework.
If it's trying to
make you sleep,
you should sleep because
otherwise you're wasting power.
There are data layer
connections between your phone
and your watch.
If a message comes
into your watch,
your app will be
given the opportunity
to handle that message.
So the
DataApi.addListener calls.
They will fire.
And you'll have the ability to
refresh the screen if something
interesting happens.
But don't refresh the
screen for no reason.
Refresh it only on demand.
And then when you're
using the alarm manager,
we have something like
the 10 second rule.
Don't try to do it
too often, but try
to keep it to within
something like 10 seconds.
And when you're using
the alarm manager,
as well, make sure that you
use the flag UpdateCurrent.
And also it's best practice
to implement single instance
launch mode.
We have a code
lab that shows you
how to do some of this stuff.
So if you come over the
code lab room next door
or if you go online
to the code labs,
you can see we have a sample
that sort of shows the bits
and pieces about how to
go about implementing this
and how to deal with
some of these issues.
So now that we've gone through
some of the code for it,
I'm now going to
hand it back to JP.
And he's going to talk more
about some of the design
best practices that you need
to take into consideration when
using Always On mode.
JP GIL: Thank you, Wayne.
So basically, when you
design watch faces or apps,
you should think about the
overall design principles
that we actually
have as guidelines
in our wearable website
design guidelines.
So when you do something
for Android Wear,
you should make apps glanceable,
actionable, relevant.
Right?
So try to focus on
only the essentials.
And when you switch
from the normal mode
to Ambient mode
to Always On, you
should even focus
more on the essentials
because if it's not
interactive, why would you
show a button there?
So make sure that you
degrade gracefully
from the active experience
to the ambient experience.
So here are a couple principles.
Use black and white.
Black and white doesn't
need a lot of power.
You can remove all
the color pixels
and just focus on
black and white.
The guidance is that you
turn off 95% of the pixels.
You're going to
save a lot of power.
Correct me if I'm
wrong, but I think
displays are the number
one consumption of power
in Android Wear, right?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: It's
one of them, yes.
It's huge.
JP GIL: It's huge.
So you can save a lot of
power by just removing color
and going black and white.
Display relevant time units.
So Wayne talked about the
example of the stopwatch.
And the framework makes
sure that your app's
not going to wake
up, but don't try
to circumvent the framework.
For example, I'm using, like,
the ultra precise stopwatch.
Let's say you want to have a
stopwatch for Formula One cars,
that you have to measure
as like a milliseconds.
That that's probably
not a good idea,
because what's the point of
going to Ambient mode if you
cannot update every millisecond?
So you'd rather not
just use Ambient mode
if you want to
actually up very often.
Remove any button, any kind
of interactive functionality,
because it's actually
going to confuse users
because, actually, the
display is turned off.
The touchscreen is turned off.
You're only going to
see the information that
is in low power mode.
You're going to have to
actually wake up the display,
go to active mode
to interact with it.
So if you put a button there,
user is going to tap on it
and nothing's going to happen.
You're going to need two taps
to actually make it happen.
Remove any sensitive content.
So for example, let's say you
have a messaging application.
Someone sends you
a private message
and it switches to
a low power mode.
And you don't even know
that it's actually off.
And you know, your information
is going to be there.
Just be conscientious
for users' privacy.
If you want to add
a clock, I think
it's something
that really helps.
The example that we showed
with the shopping list,
and Wayne mentioned
as well, is you
have the advantage
to actually show
two things at the same time.
And time is always something
that's useful for people.
So if you have the space
and the UI allows for it,
just show a little time.
Like you have an example there.
We kept a little
clock pill on the top.
All the examples
of best practices
includes to be efficient
with interactive and ambient.
So don't try to just add
more functionality in ambient
because it's not going
to be useful because you
can interact with it.
So just remove the
stuff that they actually
need-- remove the stuff they
actually don't need, I'm sorry.
That sounded confusing.
Remove the stuff that
you actually don't need
and just leave the stuff that's
relevant for that use case.
In the case of the QR code,
you just leave the QR code.
It is the cue that you actually
need to just touch and turn
on the active mode
to actually use it.
Choose the right
approach for the updates.
So going back to
the timer example.
If the timer is, like,
one hour, you probably
don't need to update
every 10 seconds.
So maybe every minute's OK.
You don't have to
say, oh, I need
to know that I have like
45 minutes and 37 seconds
left for my timer.
It's probably not so useful.
Maybe you want to get
down to the minute,
you start thinking of a
more precise update time.
But remember, every time
you update more often you're
going to need more power.
And last, make sure that
you test it on your wrist.
As a designer for
Android Wear, sometimes
I just design something
on the screen and I say,
oh, that's awesome.
And then I put it on my
wrist, I look at it, like, no.
That's not awesome.
So basically, design
your experiences.
Walk around.
Go outside.
See if the Ambient mode
also works outside.
Can you read it?
Does it make sense?
So there's tools
available out there
like Android Design
Preview or you
can see mocks on the display
so you know how it looks like.
And that's also for developers.
Don't just do everything
on the emulator.
Test it on the watch and make
sure that it works as well.
All right.
So as Wayne
mentioned, we're going
to have a Code Lab in the Code
Lab room from 2:00 to 4:00.
I'm going to be there
to answer questions
about interactive
watch faces and Always
On mode from user
experience perspective.
And we have interactive
watch face samples
on our GitHub repository.
And just join our community
if you have more questions.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
We're going have a whole bunch
of people in the room next door
from Android Wear team.
I'm going to be there.
JP will be there,
a few other people.
So if you've got questions about
it, feel free to come over.
And also try out the Code
Labs that we have as well.
It's a great opportunity to
sit down and sort of work
through some of the things
we just talked about.
They kind of guide you through
the steps and it's really easy.
And if you can't make
it to those sessions,
remember we've got our Android
Wear developers group on G+.
So it's g.co/AndroidWearDev.
Feel free to join that.
And we have like
20,000 people there
who-- you can post questions
and someone like me
or other people
will answer them.
And we have discussions
about things.
We have blog posts that go out.
So there's a lot of
really cool information.
So make sure you follow that
group and follow us on Google+
and Twitter.
And otherwise, that's about it.
So thank you very
much for coming
and we look forward to any
questions you might have.
Thank you.
Any questions?
Did you have one back there?
No?
One other thing also,
is that the samples are
available in Android Studio.
And Android Studio has
this great sample feature
that some people haven't
heard of where you just
go new, import, sample.
You type name and it imports
it straight out of GitHub
and checks it out.
And you can just hit
the build button.
Within like 30 seconds
you're building it.
It's on your phone
and your watch.
So it's definitely a really
cool thing that a lot of people
don't know about.
So it's kind of nice.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So you recommend to show
the clock on Ambient Mode.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I've noticed
every watch face
I install, I have to set 24 hour
time or month/day or day/month.
Is there a global setting
available in Android Wear where
I can just say, as an
application developer, just
show it how the user
is usually seeing it?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: I think Android
Wear does locales correctly,
but if the developer
of the app doesn't
draw the clock correctly--
so for example,
if the app developer says,
retrieve the number of hours
as an integer and
then just draw it,
there is no way the locale
support can override it.
But if you actually use Java
correctly you can actually say,
give me this value in the
correctly formatted time
for this person.
AUDIENCE: So it will just
use the phone locale?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah,
if it's done correctly.
But the problem
is a lot of people
probably aren't doing it
right, and so their app insists
on having check boxes
to control the--
AUDIENCE: Pretty much every
watch face I've seen requires
that and it's--
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
I mean, because there are
calls in the API of Android
Wear if you say, take
this time and rendered
as a string for me, and
it will do it correctly
based on the locale you're in.
But if they're not
doing it right-- so
it's kind of a bug in the
implementation of each one.
Unfortunately, you'd have
to contact the developer
and say, hey you didn't do
this locale stuff right.
But, yeah.
The watch can't override it
if you're not using the API
correctly, unfortunately.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So
the question was,
there was a slide
where the mock up
showed the clock moving
during one of the slides,
and what was the deal with that?
So let's see if
we can find that.
Is that this one?
JP GIL: It's right in the
beginning of the presentation.
Probably the second slide.
This one.
Yeah.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
Both are different.
JP GIL: Go back one.
Yeah, exactly.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Ah, that one.
Oh, yeah.
That's a feature of watch faces.
So in the watch face
API, a watch face
has the ability to
ask the framework, hey
what cards have popped
up and how high are they
up on the screen?
So you have the ability
to resize your content
or shift it around or
whatever you want to do.
So if you have an
analog watch face
you could shrink
it so that it fits.
So there is a-- as part of
the watch face framework,
it does have the
ability to crew that.
Now, not all watch faces do it.
If you've got a clock
that's very at the top,
anyway, you don't
need to do anything.
But if you have some
kind of watch face
where, for some reason,
you want to have everything
at the bottom, it might
be good to resize it,
but you have full
control over that.
JP GIL: Yeah.
As he said, there
are some watch faces
that do a really
good job at that.
They actually scale
very nicely and neatly
and it works in app devices.
But if you just provide
enough safe area,
you don't have to deal with it.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
Any more questions?
OK.
Well otherwise, as I said,
we've got office hours starting
at 2:00 in the Code Lab room.
So please come by and
have a chat with us
and try it all out.
Otherwise, thanks for coming.
JP GIL: Thank you.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: All right.
Have a good conference.